this program is brought to you by Emory
University
I'm Paul root Wolpe I'm the director of
the Center for Ethics here at Emory and
I will moderate this session I'm as
anxious as you are to hear what Donna
michelle have to say to researchers
whose work I know about and then think
it's just you're just gonna really enjoy
what they have to say science works in
in many different ways one way it works
is when a perceptive researcher notices
something sometimes that no one's
noticed before sometimes that lots of
people have noticed before I remember a
friend of mine Michaels as Lowe
discovered a group of antibiotic
molecules because he noticed something
that thousands and thousands of people
had seen before and never really paid
attention to which was after they did
experiments on frogs and dropped them
back into the dirty water they never got
infections which every biology teacher
and the history of man had all had done
but had never really said why don't they
ever get infections and Michael's Aslan
discovered this group because he finally
asked the question so there are
scientists that notice things and make
great discoveries from that Don Stein is
one of them nearly 25 years ago he
noticed that male and female rats fared
very differently after brain injuries
female rats recovering more readily than
male rats and the groundbreaking work
that that led to Don will talk about
today Don Stein is the Aizu Greg handler
professor of emergency medicine at the
Emory School of Medicine and director of
the department's brain Research
Laboratory was at one point the Dean of
Emory's graduate school and vice provost
for graduate studies Michele lampole is
a physician scientist with research
focused on human growth and development
another way science works sometimes is
there are these arguments that people
have about what is true and what isn't
true
I remember I used to assign a article to
my students I'm a sociologist in early
in my career I taught just general
sociology courses quite often and one in
intro to sociology I always used to give
this article called what is obvious and
it asked questions of students of what
they thought was obvious and then it
showed how actually at one time that
wasn't obvious at all but through the
work of social scientists establishing
that something was in fact true between
two things that seemed equally possibly
true the one that was discovered to be
in fact true
after that establishment became obvious
to everybody how true it was but before
was established to be true people
thought both some people thought one
side was obviously true some people
thought the other side of this obviously
true and I think Michelle's work shows
that we're not always sure what's
exactly obvious until it's established
and what dr. Lempel has established is
not only the truth out but the nature of
growth spurts as the father of two
daughters I remember them well I
remember the moments when my daughters
consumed every single thing in the
refrigerator without actually sitting
down
dr. Lampa was a co-director of the
university strategic plan for preventive
health associate director of preventive
health in the center for health
discovery and well-being and she was
elected a American Association for the
Advancement of science fellow last year
also as a recipient of the Emory
Williams Award for outstanding teaching
so you're in for a real treat today and
we'll start with Don Stein it's a great
pleasure for me to be back I see a lot
of old friends that I've known for many
many years in fact as long as I've been
at Emory which is now over slightly over
15 years so it really is a great
pleasure and an honor really for me to
be able to come and tell you what I've
been doing these last 15 years at Emory
and even beyond you know the session is
known as a preserving hope and
predicting health and I want to talk a
little bit about preserving hope in the
context of what we've done you heard
about the fact that when I started my
research
my research career is over 45 years I
guess I was begin I'd be Gandalf
recovery from brain injury back in the
1960s and it was all because of the
event of an observation that I had made
that my professors thought I shouldn't
bother to look at and that in those days
I was studying learning and memory and I
had some great teachers and we were
damaging a part of the brain known as
the hippocampus that's a part of the
brain that's supposed to supposedly
involved in memory storage short and
long-term memory and I was doing this
work contented as a graduate student and
I was doing these lesions I was trained
to do the surgery to remove this
structure and look at the deficits that
followed everything was going along fine
and then I noticed that about 30% of my
animals were perfectly normal and I knew
I had done the surgery on time so my
first response is Oh nuts
I've done really bad surgery and you
know I've got it now add more animals so
this is a surgical group but when I went
and we moved the brains to do the
histology those animals that did
perfectly normal had had the third it
had the very sister sent of them had
very severe injuries and no behavioral
impairments whatsoever so when I went to
my professor and I said you know Dan
there's an interesting finding we've got
30% of these animals looking perfectly
normal on all of these behavioral tests
were running and he said don't study
that he said it's just normal variation
and if you start trying to mess around
with that he'll be spending the rest of
your life here is a PhD student rather
than getting your degree and I had a
baby and a young wife and you know
$1,800 a year stipend so I had to play a
little politics here and I managed to
finish up and go to MIT where I began to
do other work in other parts of the
brain and so the same kind of phenomenon
that you could get a lot of damage in
depending on how that damage was
inflicted and still get a lot of
functional recovery and this was a
puzzle because in the day that I was a
student and as a young professor we were
teaching and being taught that once the
adult brain is injured there's no repair
there's no regeneration and all you can
hope for is some type of retraining
that's what rehabilitation is all about
is to teach you to cope with the deficit
that you're just going to have to live
with for the rest
and I got the same story at MIT this is
you know not something that's worthy of
serious study everybody knows how the
brain is localized and has all these
different functions and once you damage
that structure that's the end of it so
you know it bothered me and I couldn't
do much about it until I got my first
job and I ended up going to a small
school my first job was at a small New
England College called Clark University
which had a history of doing very funky
work that was where a Robert Goddard the
space pioneer was and that's where they
developed the pill with Hudson colon and
Gregory Pincus so it's a very kind of
odd place and they let me explore all
this stuff and that's where we first
made the observation when I was looking
at still in all these laboratory rats
that we decided to look at sex
differences why because no one else was
doing it you know to this day when you
look at most of the neuroscience
literature probably 90% of all studies
in the laboratory are done with with
male rats so nobody really knows a lot
about when you're developing drugs when
you develop a treatment what the
differences are between males and
females so we decided to look at this
and what we found was that when we
damage the brains big serious injury -
and both males and females the females
recovered better they recovered much
better there was some clinical evidence
to suggest that this was a real
phenomena but it would these kind of
anecdote case study reports nothing
really systematic a scientific when we
pursue this a little bit further than
what we found out was it true females do
recover better than males but it
depended on where they were in their
estrus cycle at the time they had their
injury and the estrus cycle is like the
human female menstrual cycle and so
being right next to the Worcester
Foundation for Experimental Biology
which was made by Clarke faculty and
which knew more about reproductive
physiology than anybody in the world cuz
that's where the pill was invented they
told us how to look at this and so we
found that if you signe varied the
hormonal level at the time of injury
without giving Howe much you could just
make the female think she was
impregnated because what happens when a
woman becomes impregnated a size of all
the other growth processes is that
estrogen levels drop and progesterone
levels go up anywhere from 50 to a
hundred times when they're not pregnant
this becomes important in the story that
I'm about to tell you so sure enough
when we damage the animals when they
hi and progesterone the outcome was far
far better than if the same injury was
done when they were high in estrogen and
the basic but what I meant by outcome is
it they had virtually no brain swelling
their performance was as good as almost
as good as a normal intact animal and
they just really did much better on any
type of behavioral testing that we could
see compared to males the next step was
let's give this to males and everybody
said you're nuts
what do you mean you're gonna give a
female hormone to male rats and see what
happens it doesn't make any sense
besides you know you it's it's just
basically a reproductive moments like I
do anything on the brain so we said well
what do we have to lose you know by this
point I had tenure and we did it and
sure enough we found that in the male
rats given just a very short course of
treatment the outcome was so much better
than if they were not given the
treatment the only difference was
whether they got a three-day treatment
following brain injury progestin this is
not at the time we weren't giving
anything pre injury so you know we then
began everybody said this just doesn't
make any sense just recently I gave it
to a look at a military health Research
Forum and I was on a work which is now
much more developed and a general got up
after my presentation and he said you
know that's all well and good doctor
Stein but don't you think this treatment
could turn some of our troops gay so I'm
not kidding no this is really this is
really some of the stereotype that you
have to deal with it's not a female
hormone let me put that straight we make
it we just don't make as much as females
but we will make it and it's synthesized
in the brain and we have the same kind
of receptor characteristics in our
brains as you women have we just don't
make as much of it but you know what was
really lucky the what was happening was
at first when we tried to proceed doing
this work you never know where it's
going to go when I tried to get federal
funding from this through the NIH and
nobody would look at this they thought
it was absolutely ridiculous but I've
been giving a talk on this it was
actually in Denmark and there was a
woman there from from one of the largest
insurance companies in the world
January insurance which is now one of
the Buffett
and she said this work is very
interesting because we we treat you know
we have to take care of workman's
compensation issues and we should see if
this stuff works maybe would help reduce
you know lifelong disability and maybe
we'd benefit from it
so that was the first way we're able to
get any funding was a $50,000 grant from
January which started all of this work
and allowed us to proceed and the last
years we've been working on looking at
all the mechanisms because a lot of the
scientists even at Emory when I came
here thought that this work was really
ridiculous
I'll mention one I won't mention any
names but there was a former dean in the
medical school of associate dean who was
a remember him telling me to my face you
know you want to get serious about your
research this is pie in the sky it's not
going to lean anywhere and that's why
you're gonna say in this double-wide
trailer you're gonna be in for the rest
of your life so he's gone the bottom
line this is it this is the kind of
recession you were you were often
subject to and in this kind of way
there's a lot of there was a lot of
skepticism but one of the great things
about my coming to Emory as a Dean was
and coming to Emory on the faculty was
it I was able to give a talk once to the
Board of Visitors and sitting in the
Board of Visitors was a guy who became
not only my very dear friend but my boss
a guy by the name of art Kohn and many
of you know him he's now a very senior
vice president of the rand cooperation
in my mind a great loss to Emory but art
is an emergency medicine doctor and said
you know this work really makes a lot of
sense because we have no treatment for
traumatic brain injury to this day after
all the years and years of research
there is no effective treatment for
traumatic brain injury and only one
treatment for stroke which is a
dangerous treatment called tissue
plasminogen activator so when you think
about it there really this is business
topic of preserving hope as a big issue
for me because most brain injury victims
especially severe brain injury victims
if they survive really have no hope of
any type of restorative therapy you can
keep them alive you can help them
compensate and many of them do very very
well but insofar as really providing for
a neuro protective treatment that
actually preserves no cells there was
nothing so art said you know you
to emergency medicine I was
transitioning back to the faculty from
my Dean's job and he said we really need
somebody like you this is a very unusual
thing for an emergency medicine doctor
to say you know you should we want to
support this kind of basic research
which is really outside of our field and
by the way that I have to make mention
also the Graduate School has been a big
supporter of this work for all the years
that we've been doing it so Lisa thank
you for that supporting but you know so
one of the big advantages of coming here
with all right he said you know this
work is so compelling we ought to go to
clinical trial and it's up three years
three full years of repeating the
workers everybody on study sections that
review the grass say this stuff it's not
gonna go anywhere it's not going to work
but finally we convinced them to support
a Phase two clinical trial this is a
safety a small safety and efficacy trial
a single center trial that began here at
Grady hospital they gave us so little
money that we couldn't even do any
functional outcome measures on the
patients but you know because they
thought it wasn't gonna work so why
squander a lot of money you know we had
enough scientists some sign to this
report but not that much that they
wanted to spend a lot and then a real
really unusual turnabout for the NIH
they called us up and they said we made
a mistake we're actually gonna find you
to do some functional ACOs we really
want to know is it not just gonna stop
brain swelling but this is gonna have
any functional benefits so the first
clinical trial with progesterone started
here at Grady Hospital under the
Department of Emergency Medicine which
is a huge shift in paradigm there's most
Charles for brain injury really go
through neurosurgery and neurology so
there's a whole major dynamic that had
to be worked out unfortunately our and
my colleague Dave Wright who worked with
me now for almost 12 years we're able to
have the political and professional
skills to get all the various medical
communities in at the Emory and Grady
facilities to work together which is no
small task the bottom-line outcome of
that hundred-person trial was that
normally when you have a severe brain
injury the mortality rate even under the
best of circumstances is about 30 32
percent mortality with severe brain
injury that's what stand in a practice
care and every patient was being given
standard of practice care or standard of
just can't plus progesterone five three
days of intravenous treatment with this
hormone cut that mortality rate down to
thirteen point six percent and improved
functional outcomes a thirty day
survival fourfold over stand in a
practice care and there was not a single
serious adverse event attributable to
treatment so that's pretty dramatic for
a phase two study so we worked on it we
continued to work out all the metabolic
pathways to look at all the genomic
regulation that's what I do in my lab is
a basic scientist and we then felt we
had enough data to go forward to apply
for a phase three multi center national
trial and with again a lot of work and a
lot of you know repetition and repeating
the grants and doing all the work that
we have to do that that was finally
funded that's a twenty eight million
dollar NIH supported you're paying for
it as taxpayers and NIU each supported
grant to have a thirty one Center though
although top level one trauma centers
across the country trust plus Brooke
Army Hospital in San Antonio are
participating in this trial so far we
have about 250 patients enrolled as a
result of this the company that makes
most of the progesterone
is also sponsoring a second phase three
trial and they have about a hundred
patients enroll all over the European
Union including centers in the United
States the European Union Israel
Singapore and China so it's really
become a major operation in a sense and
this trial will in these two trials will
enroll close to three thousand patients
and if it works and so far none of the
trials have there been any adverse
events through the treatment which is
again pretty amazing because now this
close to 600 patients there was a
complete replication of this worked from
China which even just took severe brain
injury patients and they looked at three
months and six months out and found
almost exactly the same results as we
did so where are we going now this is an
amazing lots of rats have sacrificed for
you and for us and for me and getting to
this point and it looks like it's good
to be very very promising what's
happening now is that it's moving off in
all kinds of new directions we're now
working again with the National
Institutes of Health to move the work
forward to stroke and our preclinical
day
I have to say this it would you this is
all published our preclinical data with
stroke is actually better than the
preclinical data we had with TBI it's
going to work I believe much more
effectively an ischemic stroke both
permanent transient than it did in TBI
and we are now traumatic brain it's
romantic brain injury sorry and we're
we're now working on what's called an
investigational new drug application to
get the FDA to approve it and to go
forward with that and so that should
start probably and that will be run by
our neurology colleague Mike Franco here
and it was also a head of the Stroke
Center down at Grady so that's going
Paul in addition to that again the
spin-offs are amazing the University of
Michigan got funding from Health and
Human Services to start planning for a
pediatric trial
looking at the use of progesterone and
severe traumatic brain injury so that's
in the planning stage and we're working
very closely with them to develop all
the preclinical data we need to inform
them as to dose and timing and
durational treatment which may be very
different for kids but in a panel of a
really a national panel of pediatric
endocrinologists when were approached on
the stage they were against this trial
they said you're wasting taxpayer money
there's no safety issue and and anything
that progesterone could possibly do
could not be worse than a severe
traumatic brain injury and kids is no
risk you should just be doing it right
now but the politics and the sociology
of science preclude that and it's
probably just as well that we get the
safety data and lastly it took years
using us has been more frustrating part
of the experience to get the military on
board you know the combat casualties in
Iraq and in Afghanistan have been very
dramatic about 30 percent of all the
surviving combat casualties in those two
theaters of war have come back with
traumatic brain injuries and now seem
even the mild ones evolved into
post-traumatic stress disorder it's a
big problem and finally we just got an
invitation after four years of working
in it finally sitting down with a number
of key surgeons general and even David
Petraeus and finally the military has
come on board now and invited us working
with the Emory Institute of drug
development here dr. Dennis Liotta to
develop a field treat
because progesterone is not very soluble
but thanks to his genius and the team
that he works with over there we've been
able to make it much more soluble make
it much more stable so that any
emergency medicine technician any
corpsman anybody a fireman anybody you
could carry this and it you know in a
site of an accident when someone's down
if you just give this and start the
treatment and we've been able to change
the volunteer slice so that's still
exactly progesterone but we've been able
to extend its to decrease its metabolic
rate it usually breaks down in ten
minutes we've been able to extend that
up to almost four hours so you could
give a feel treatment so that by the
time you get the person to the hospital
for final treatment for the three day
course of treatment you've already
preserved a lot of brain tissue because
the sooner you treat from a stroke or
brain injury the better the outcome is
going to be so one of the other things I
just want to mention the FDA in this
phase three clinical trial which is
being run as I said out of out of Emory
and down at Grady but all over the
country
they gave waiver of informed consent for
this treatment may be well we'll have
more to say about that they felt the
safety profile is so high and the risk
of injury to the patient's so low that
the sooner you get the treatment if you
don't have to get proxy consent from a
severely brain injured or even
moderately brain injury patients you're
gonna get better outcome so they've
actually given us waiver of informed
consent which is really a very big vote
of confidence in what we're doing so I
think we are now finally maybe can not
only offer but preserve hope for a lot
of these people who have up to now had
no possibilities for these treatments
and I think the Emory experience for me
you know there's everybody every faculty
member can complain does your
frustrations and those your ups and
downs you know with your struggles with
grants and all those other things that
always get in the way of research but I
think none of this could have happened
if it wasn't for me being here and it
wasn't for the wonderful team from the
graduate school to the people at Grady
to my faculty colleagues here in
emergency medicine it's been an
incredible ride and I think in the final
analysis worth all the frustration and
aggravation that sometimes is a
thank you thank you very much and that's
a wonderful lead-in to the opportunity
to talk to you about what we're doing in
predictive health and we have the great
fortune to be in a mecca of health
resources in the United States within
five miles of the Center for Disease
Control the home of American Cancer
Society and a number of other absolutely
amazing resources and to be at a
university with rich breath and depth in
health and it is that largesse that led
to the initiatives taken by our
president when he came here to begin to
focus on what are our assets and how can
we really make those signatures of Emory
so it's my pleasure to be talking about
predicting health and it's a wonderful
topic because the the lead in that
you've given us is so wonderful that our
system of healthcare has the amazing
distinction of absolutely not being
oriented towards health we are entirely
focused on what happens when you don't
have it and I must say when I went to
medical school I was already a PhD with
an interest in normal processes and I
was severely disappointed by my
experience in medical school because
there was no health or normality on the
horizon and I found that to be
fundamentally disturbing so coming full
circle and being able to participate in
an effort to frankly define health
scientifically is an incredible
experience and a great challenge for all
of us so as I work in the way that I'll
tell you about in a few minutes
forward to bring to the Emory College at
this moment in particular a focus on
Health Week hi we call it assignment
health and in fact it's a national issue
at this time to try and tackle what can
we do
I followed Dawn's incredibly intriguing
amazing
vulgarity and scientific discoveries by
saying that we live in what both the
best of times for all the reasons that
he has described we know more about
disease and pathology and what to do
about it how to fix it with drugs for
infectious disease in particular then
certainly we ever known in mankind's
history
but we also live in the worst of times
in the strange way which is for all the
things that we have survived we have a
worse outcome for our children than we
did in terms of their health that should
cause everyone to stop and hail and
think so the statistics and we'll just
start there because therein lie the
beginnings of predictive health range
from a kind of digital panel that one in
three American children are obese well
why does that matter because we don't
live in a world of infectious disease
where extra fat and calories is going to
get you through but actually that
predicts a consequential sequence of
events that's actually quite serious for
the rest of their lives so if we cut to
the chase you know these lakes were made
for walking they're not actually
appendages to the couch and our bodies
were made for challenges of insecure
circumstances not for 24/7 high-fat
high-calorie yummies and therein is the
consequential circumstances in which we
find ourselves in the United States
today which is one problem but here's
the second part but that's exactly
what's going to happen globally that the
global health picture is following the
United States health picture at this
time and there's two parts to that
because there's been a great surge in
the United States about global health
and I just think we would all share that
that's very important but the United
States as part of the global health
community and the seriousness of the
chronic diseases in our own in our own
country these at this time is somehow
not quite sharing in the enthusiasm for
health care that sometimes I
think we nationally support that said
here's some statistics more than 70% of
a veil of avoidable morbidity and
mortality is due to behavior more than
70% that said in 2007 only 3% of health
care dollars were spent on prevention
this is a stunning statistic the United
States spends more than any other
industrialized country we have the 45th
best health record we have the 33rd best
maternal mortality which is specifically
means women who survived childbirth and
in the state of Georgia worth 50th so I
put those statistics out there and those
are the statistics and one of my core
classes and predictive health but I want
people to walk out of there and know so
that they can be informed citizens as we
construct and argue about health care in
the United States today as well as their
investment potential for what we need to
do to move ourselves into a healthier
zone and my predictive health is focused
and has its origin on those statistics
we cannot afford health care in the
United States at this time to deal with
chronic disease and in that milieu
the ideas that I'm now going to talk to
you about were started and it came out
of a conversation of many people but was
led by Mike Johns at Emory in
collaboration with one of his colleagues
dawn Gibbons at Georgia Tech and in a
very serious conversation they sat down
and said look it's a no-brainer if we're
causing our ill health we need to take
the time and focus attention on how what
can we do about this how can we begin to
intervene now that's the beginning of
what many of us would obviously say as
we need to be able to prevent what we
to prevent and since that seems
perfectly obvious what's the problem the
problem is here on the number one side
is Finance I've told you about three
percent of our expenditures are actually
given to public health and prevention my
colleagues who work on these issues in
the school of public health come back
from Capitol Hill and say you know it's
really difficult to sell the absence of
something it's really hard to get up
there and encourage people to get
excited about preventing something and
in the absence of something it's much
easier to get up there and say let's
invest in a disease so that's a
fundamentally interesting and incredible
challenge what is the challenge
fundamentally about it's fundamentally
about the definition of health so at the
moment we we function in a society that
takes health is what is left over if
you're not sick and nothing else going
wrong well that rest of that stuff is
help and in some sense is that
scientifically we don't have a study of
health and conceptually in our culture
we don't even have an ontology of health
what is health and that seems like a
really simple question but when I put it
to my students the knee-jerk response is
to google it and Gavin secret Webster
says health is must finally default to
World Health Organization that has a
very nice summary statement which is
it's not just the absence of disease
it's about well-being but then if you
start studying well-being somehow we get
caught up in the a near enola image it's
when you kind of feel good that's when
you kind of do good things for yourself
these health after all a lot of people's
new jerk response is exercise or the
pyramid until the day before yesterday
we know it's the plate but by and large
in an investigation of people's
responses when I ask them what is health
that's the kind of process that they
engage in
it's everything that I should do but I
don't do so becomes very personal and
very behavioural one of our major goals
at Emory
is to take on this challenge and define
health and to begin to work on the
science of health and that is something
that we are particularly excellent at
and we have the breadth and depth of
faculty and research scientists who are
beginning to write the text for the
science of health and that's very
exciting and in that core research we
have a core concept of health and what
that's about we could tell you each and
every one of you in the room today where
you were kind of in that realm and the
four concepts were the four sets of data
that we're working with that our
colleagues have described are very
simple really first of all the body
turns over all the time so there has a
basic regenerative potential and you
don't necessarily think about this but
the lining of your intestines turn over
every 72 hours so the cells that are
desorbing today only have a 72 hour life
cycle and you'll have new ones in a few
days the bones on the other hand some
people tell us take 10 years to
completely turn over so the legs you're
standing on are actually not the same
waves you were standing on ten years ago
now herein lies the problem that's great
as long as everything that goes away is
replaced the problem comes when war goes
away than is replaced and there we have
for example osteoporosis so the
regenerative potential of the body is
very important without which we really
are in a pickle that's an anatomical
fact then we have three processes that
influence our health and in fact they
also influences the stunt the stem-cell
regenerative potential by the way but
they influence many other things the
immune system really very important you
need to keep what's there there and
what's not not you need to identify
invaders make them go away
very good bad side normally what that
involves is inflammation so when the
immune system gets revved up and does
its thing creates a chemical cascade
it's the right thing to do until it does
it too often now that's very interesting
and some of the great work that's going
on at Emory right now talks about
exactly that point inflammation is
something you know when you cut yourself
and you put your hand on the part that
you cut yourself and it's very hot
that's what most people think of when
they think of inflammation it hurts it's
hot
the problem is inflammation can also be
there and you can't see it and from the
body's perspective it shoots out an
inflammatory response under all kinds of
circumstances you might not really think
about and the great spokesperson for
that particular angle is dr. Chuck razn
so if you've ever heard him speak you
know this and if you haven't oh you must
listen to him he is our CNN
correspondent for behavior at the moment
from Emory so you might know him from
that venue the bottom line is he has a
very elegant work that's showing that
when you are anxious your body does
exactly the same thing as it does when
you cut your finger it pours out an
inflammatory response so the notion that
stress is bad for your health
he's clearly documented the why he's
also clearly documented together with
some of our colleagues through the
contemplative meditation program but
then you can really do something about
that and meditation has been documented
to decrease inflammatory response so the
skills out there that we have to show
how these fundamental processes affect
your health are unique to Emory and the
fourth fundamental process then after
the stem cells immune system
inflammation is oxygen now most of us
think you know door oxide to the better
because we do have to breathe but
actually the more oxygen is not the
better from the viewpoint of the cells
and all of these things that you hear
about antioxidants their purpose is
because from the viewpoint of the cell
too much oxygen is actually a bad thing
and it's destructive so knowing this
that's a little package
we can call court health and if we can
look at for each of us where do we sit
how do you define yourself in these four
processes you'd have a thumbprint a
fingerprint of your health
that's a fantastically new concept and
it is the first true definition of
health that we have from a very
scientific viewpoint but the beauty of
it is that it pulls together everything
else that you do in your life what makes
you happy so that you're not stressed I
had a colleague yesterday who said to me
this is a wonderful new definition
because in general we think about health
as being some professional thing with
medication but she said you know I was
an English major and if I realised that
what's important to my health is to not
be stressed and to feel happy then what
makes me happiest is going to the
theatre and if that's good for my health
I'm going to continue to go to the
theatre because it's not my job and it's
not money and in that moment was the
best pitch I've heard in a long time for
a liberal arts education and I mean that
every person in the end lives in a
health sphere that is fundamentally
defined by who they are so that's where
we are in the science of predictive
health it is a new way of thinking about
health and in every predictive health we
have a goal that's no smaller than
changing healthcare at large
it's a ground-up effort but it's a very
well-grounded effort and it has the
potential of fantastic effects now that
said the second big claim against oh you
can't possibly affect this and change
anything feels nobody changes behavior
so you're in a really doomed attempt
behavioral change is a great challenge
indeed we all know whether it's you
wanted to stop smoking or you wanted to
eat less so you needed to start
exercising or pick pick your pick your
poison you don't decide one day and
next day well you might do it the next
day and three weeks later well that was
my effort or you fell in a hole walking
and that was exactly what you got for
trying to exercise so how do we do that
and how do we tackle that end we're also
working on that and in the Center for
Health Discovery we've had some
wonderful outcomes for the model that we
are research our research has begun and
in the center we've developed a model of
a health partner working with an
individual so we're working on the level
of personal health but the protocol is
very simple it's educate give you the
information let me give you your
thumbprint back on where your health
status is today and then I work with you
and try and engage you in what do you
want from this do you want to be healthy
you want to be healthier and if so what
can we do about it what are your values
you have to be invested in wanting to do
something before you're going to do it
and that relationship sets that
groundwork and finally we empower people
give them a toolkit for what to do to
actually be able to make behavior change
and with that piece of predictive health
with that knowledge base with that proof
if you will it became clear to me since
my appointment is in the college that
the best hope for the future is to
educate certainly starting at even
younger levels but I work in the college
at college and the great transition from
adolescence to adulthood and we really
wanted to take the model that we did a
predictive health and deliver it back to
the undergraduates now that is my
long-term idealistic hope at this time
it's prohibitively expensive to do
exactly what we do in the center for
every incoming undergraduate since there
are 1,300 to the 36 of them and it's
about $800 no profit at this time do the
math I'm looking forward to a great
infusion of
interests an investment at some point
but right now what we started to do is
and we're going to roll it out in August
and I take the last moment to talk about
that we're gonna roll out a
collaboration predictive health in the
college and we're taking the best of the
model of predicting health and we've
created a new freshman health
requirement the one credit unit which is
exactly what we've just described which
is the predictive health model and that
endeavor has been created through a
collaboration of one of our best health
partners in case anybody goes to the
health center it's Lisa Dupree and
several people from PE and I have driven
this forward to deliver 12 weeks of a
predictive health model that I'm really
excited and really happy to share with
you and happy to talk more about but
welcome to predictive health and I'm
really excited to talk to you more as
the questions are appropriate thank you
for your attention
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University